talks with book TV from the 2010 Book
Expo America in New York City he
discusses his memoir hitch 22 for half
an hour
Christopher Hitchens who talked you into
doing an autobiography I think it may
well have been the person who wrote Maya
bitchery by accident
in the catalogue of the National
Portrait Gallery in London a couple of
years ago there was a an exhibit about a
group of people friends of mine and of
Martin anuses a sort of set if you like
and in the catalog copy referred to the
late Christopher Hitchens and they were
terribly upset and said don't worry
we'll recall them all will pulp the
whole thing and I said no no I want
several copies of that because nothing
focuses the mind like reading about
yourself in the past tense and it
immediately dissolved any objection I
had when I was asked to do a memoir
which is what isn't it too early I think
well I certainly can't leave it to it's
too late so there was that and then
mm-hmm I told my son excuse me I talked
myself into it a bit because I didn't
much mind being 40 or 50 I barely
noticed it but 60 hit me harder than I
thought it would and I found I was
looking backwards quite a lot brooding
on things so this is probably the right
moment to do it
why hits 22
well I end up having described a lot of
commitments I've had in my life and a
lot of ideological battles I've taken
part in with the general polemic against
certainty and against purity against
consistency if you like I'm no longer a
member of any party or any biological
grouping but I am associated with a
group of skeptics who are sure of one
thing which is the nothing's for sure
and you're absolutely certain about the
uncertainty principle and so my hitch 22
is that my commitment is entirely to D
to doubt so that's the idea and then
there was a game I have a lot of word
games in the book some of them very pure
are indeed schoolboy humor but getting
better as time goes on and one of them
is a game invented by Salman Rushdie
where you have to think of a book title
it didn't quite make it for whom the
bell rings for example or mr. Shivaji or
good expectations was another one a
farewell to weapons portrait of a woman
and one that he considers you that she
was hitched ready to and I thought yes I
think I might borrow that death is a
theme in your body yes why well because
because I begin with my own obituary
accidental initially then because it's
not an autobiography exactly but it I
thought that everyone doing a memoir
they have to do one chapter each about
their parents and death I'm afraid as a
big subject there because my mother took
her own life in very tragic
circumstances their dramatic tragic
substance that I described and my father
was in the war business he was a
lifelong naval officer it had a very
tough war and I was brought up entirely
on stories of chiefly British valour at
sea
and on landing in the air I mean it was
I can't remember how old I was so I
realized that all television all books
and all films were not about the Second
World War I thought they were
chapter about your mother Yvonne yes I
could've um well because it was her name
and because that's what I used to call
her she liked it
and because it's a nice name
and it's the way when I think about I
don't I don't think money I think or
mama or I think Yvonne we were very
close and
and I also used to think cuz we came
from a slightly drab part of English
societies of lower middle-class with
aspirations naval and military and my
mother was a sort of failed milliner she
kept trying to open dress shops that
never quite made it and so the sort of
the wives of my father's brother
officers will call things like Ethel or
Marjorie or Nancy who names like that
and I always thought when I was little
that Yvonne had a touch of class to it a
little bit more cosmopolitan perhaps a
bit more stylish bit more Swan yay and
she was that in my life she I described
her as the Djinn in the Campari and the
cream in the coffee she was cheerful and
humorous and once said to me that the
really only the really only unforgivable
sin was to be boring which is haunted me
all my life fear of bores fear of
becoming a bore or being boring terror
starts Arabic idiom
yes it's with me always I mean if I
think it's probably the most devastating
word that one can use against somebody
or or risk having used against yourself
yes don't be boring not only boring
this book is full of names bold-faced
names as I say I'm just gonna throw some
out and have you respond Martin Amis
yes who is he what's his relationship
well Martin is as I'm sure loyal
audience will know is he
brilliant novelist both humor and of
gravity
I mean he's written novels about the
Holocaust and about the good I got the
pail ago but he's also written I think
with his best humorous one best-known
one is called money which is study of so
anglo-american degeneracy and the the
cusp of the 1980s in which I appear once
or twice fairly heavily disguised and
he's my best friend and has been since
we were in our twenties and a chapter of
the book is basically a sort of love
letters Martin and I I'd say in the in
that chapter that the question I'm
trying to answer is phrase it like this
can you have a heterosexual relationship
with another guy so I don't know whether
you can or not but I decided to give it
the sort of old college try and I
destroyed the influence he had on my
writing the way in which we used to have
very long languorous very tender very
intense discussions about women
the inexhaustible subject
and I show how you can make lead into
gold because I described a visit we both
made to a terrible massage parlour
brothel outfit in New York which he had
to go to because his character and money
John self had to go and expose himself
for this so it was fieldwork and it was
the most intensely sordid and horrible
and depressing shameful really morning
of my life I think and for him -
absolutely ghastly you can read it in
money I even give the page reference and
I thought when I read that section John
selfs Fiasco in the massage bar I
thought well that whole morning of
squalor and misery it's now be sort of
totally redeemed it's become literature
it's an almost pristine moment he
actually you can what get wasted lost
time back and feel it wasn't squandered
off after all so I do if I'm giving you
a hint and you know he's been a great
source of enthusiasm and risk and so on
in my life James Fenton you dedicate the
bullet to him James some changed my life
I met him at Oxford in the late 60s
where we were exactly temporaries he is
I think easily the finest poet writing
in English least of his generation now
and
probably best known to your audience for
the perm she wrote from Indochina it's a
surprising thing when you think about it
there's almost no poetry generated by
the Vietnam War or if there is there
isn't a poem everybody knows as they
have been parents and other Wars the
best is written by James I quote some of
it and he as well as Martin and a few
others taught me that there was more to
writing and mortar journalism than
polemic no I used to think that the test
of a good article was how well I'd
argued the case how well I had sort of
laid out the arguments for the left how
bad I could make the right wing look how
I'd marshaled the arguments it was all
very didactic and though James like me
was very much to the left so here it
mattered much more how the article was
written making every word count using
irony and understatement and humor and
we actually even wrote a couple of
articles together the HIV vote on a
joint byline with anybody and he was he
was immensely influential on me in that
way I think prevention we part some
becoming boring to revert to the the
death trap subject
Peter Sedgwick yes Peter session would
be less well known to audience but he
was a he's a Marxist intellectual of a
very rarefied kind in other words he he
was one of those people who was of the
left of the left the left against the
left
very very artists honest very much
against some of the cult figures of the
sixties like Herbert Marcuse
& RG Lang who were being much bandied
about they were conjuring names when
when I was beginning to cut my teeth he
thought the sixties were probably a bit
of a false promise the counterculture
didn't interest him very much
he was a scientist as a psychiatrist
believed in objectivity wasn't easily
swayed introduced me to this little
dissident Marxist tradition of writing
Rosa Luxemburg particularly some of Leon
Trotsky George Orwell the great CLR
James the great West Indian historian
who wrote the best really the only book
on the Haitian Revolution it's called
black Jacobins fantastic book about the
slave rebellion in Haiti and also
incidentally was the best writer on
Cricut has ever been produced by the
British Empire an odd thing for a
revolutionary to be doing but that was
the thing about Peter I introduced you
to idiosyncratic types the sort of
tradition of the Revolution he left that
got buried by the Hitler Stalin pact and
by the Cold War and which was something
of a revival in the 60s and 70s
Salman Rushdie
well some on a vertical chapter to him
and to his cause because I was just
getting to know him I'd become a friend
of his when he suddenly became even more
famous than he thought he was gonna
become and even more well known for his
writing all in all of one go rather
unfortunately by dint of getting an
incredibly bad review from the Ayatollah
Khomeini who as well as not content with
a bad review offered money in his own
name to suborn Salmons murder an
unbelievable sort of frontal attack on
civilisation so for many years he had to
go into hiding and be off the map and
there were a number of us who were very
proud to be his friend at that time sort
of arranged keep in touch with him keep
up his spirits he was afraid at one
point not so much that they would find
him and kill him but that the effort of
staying alive would mean he couldn't
right turns out he was wrong to fear
that he's written a lot of great stuff
since then he's very emblematic figure
of the of the 20th century the the idea
of the intellectual migrant the person
who's at home in two continents it's
incredible to me that English's is only
his second language first languages
audio he writes it and I would say
speaks it really better than any native
speaker does and as I say he hugely
improved the level of our rather
childish boy boyish school boyish word
games I'll give you an example he was
once asked without any preparation what
would a Shakespeare play be titled if
Robert Ludlum was I won't tell you how
that all came up takes too long with
just picture if you will it look wrote
love the naming a Shakespeare places
someone said okay try me and was okay
Hamlet and he said the Elsinore
vacillation just like that don't believe
it be clever I said okay I bet you can't
do that twice with Macbeth says the
Dunsinane deforestation
for a feller the kerchief implication
for the Merchant of Venice the rialto
sanction Oh like that are there some
more in the book he has a real hold on
English literature he he he loves it and
really knows it and in addition because
if that wasn't enough he's become one of
the great symbolic figures in them in
the Battle of over free expression which
never ends
we never thought perhaps we would have
to defend the First Amendment against
such an incredibly fantastically violent
fundamental literally fundamentalist
assault but I think it was right to
notice when the hour had struck when it
did proud to have had anything to do
with that go on at length that if you
were taking the citizenship test oh yes
yeah shortly after 9/11 I realized I've
been living in the States for a long
time more than two decades nearly three
I had a green card that was so old they
didn't have an expiration date on it was
one of those old ones these together a
platinum green card you might say I had
three American children an American wife
it's unlikely I'd get deported and I had
a European Union passport in a green car
I could have gone on like that
happily beings of anglo-american for the
rest of my days but I thought I began to
feel I was sort of cheating on my dears
but I should I've really felt a strong
solidarity with American society after
that appalling attack on it just down
the road from here and began to feel
much more like an American even strange
to feel more like a Washingtonian I mean
I Washington was more like my base I
used to take strong identification so I
applied and well it's got very hard to
do the people at these days they kept on
making appointments and then breaking
them and
putting them off whatever then they sent
me an exam which I think even had the
answers in it about questions you might
be asked at an interview and some of
them will rather trivial like what are
the advantages of becoming an American
citizen you you you wanted to think
there would be some something noble
could be said there you looked at the
answers given by the official term has
said you can apply for a job in the
federal government and you can bring
your relatives in from that overseas as
well one would hope one can we make
those states can say a bit more for
itself than that then there are
questions where you mustn't try and be
funny like against whom did we fight in
the American Revolution well I think the
answer is the user ping Hanoverian royal
family that had used up Perrin Britain
but the correct answer is the British so
you have to get all that right it's a
bit dispiriting but I set up the night
before
not in any fear of failing the exam but
I just said haven't read through the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights and
I have a section in there about how you
can read off the whole history of
America by looking at the dates of those
amendments the the ways in which they
came about and it's very nice because
it's nice in itself is actually does
demonstrate progress which sometimes you
wonder about second we'll have doubts
about second it shows where this is it's
a great country for a writer because
it's based on written documents which
are deliberately there in order to
expose themselves to rewrite their work
in progress they can be revised so that
the words and the music of the words and
the meaning of them and the legality of
them are all very important and that's
the unique privilege I think so
then I was able by good luck to get the
department for my security to allow me
to have my ceremony take the earth at
the Jefferson Memorial in Washington DC
on his birthday in 13th April which is
also mine and I'd by then written a
short biography of him and I held a copy
of the Virginia statute on religious
freedom which was one of the four things
he wanted to be remembered for and that
was that was a wonderful day
really was
sylvia plath
so the path keeps on coming up in my
story because she wrote about two things
well she didn't write about suicide she
committed suicide but she's the occasion
of an enormous number of books about
female self-destruction and I have to I
did just write a chapter about my
mother's cell sort of suicide but I also
write a coda a short chapter my
reflections on suicide meant the Plath
story keeps coming up in that and then
in one of her most famous lines it's in
the bell jar she describes her family
coming from some manic-depressive Hamlet
in the German Polish border lands and it
so happens that that's where my mother's
family comes from it was a secret kept
in my family for a long time I didn't
fight it out till I was about thirty but
my mother's family was of Jewish descent
from what is now Poland but was then
Germany
it's always very horrible when that
border moves at any time European
history terrible things happen when that
border changes and I have a chapter on
why I think it is that she kept her
secret from my father and from two sons
and for every one she knew almost she
died before we could have the
conversation and I make a routes trip I
go to Poland find the old shtetl and
see if I can find any traces of any
remaining relatives no it's a clean
sweep they're all they're all dead they
will be murdered by fascism and so the
the Sylvia Plath's concept of the
manic-depressive Hamlet comes very alive
to me on that trip Peter Hitchens
he did this is my younger brother he was
born two years after me slightly too
close laughs I used to not to notice
about things like birth order and all
these articles you read about it I
didn't actually I think it's quite
important and things for potential
parents to think about if you have a
brother who's actually was more like
eighteen months younger than me he's too
close to be a baby brother but close
enough to be arrival for of all things
my mother's attention oh my god imagine
how I must have felt
I don't remember it but I'm told that I
became very jealous and I can believe it
and as siblings we've never been very
close we haven't lived in the same town
since we were quite small
he lives in Oxford now and he he's a
very well-known newspaper and broadcast
newspaper columnist and broadcaster in
England of the extreme right he's also
very well known as a Christian believer
that he's even written to a book you I
hope you'll do something about it it's
come out it's coming out this month or
so it's called the rage against God
subtitle is how atheism letters your
faith and it's a it's in part an
extended dialogue with me from my
unbelief and for me anyway the biggest
difference I could have with anyone is
no matter all political differences
absolutely dwarfed by the difference
between those who believe believe
there's a supernatural dimension like
him and there's slightly you do not and
it's the basis really of all other
arguments that's where philosophy begins
it's where arguments why biology
actually begin to so he is I have to say
very good writer here's a Hitchens after
all he's very serious person I think a
bit more solemn than neither haps
and when I say right-wing I mean
genuinely right-wing in other words he's
people people who regard things like the
argument over erupted for it for
instance as a left-right one I was think
have it wrong because in my experience
anyway the Iraqi and Kurdish left group
friends of mine Roy in favor of removing
Saddam Hussein large numbers of the
American right people at Pat Buchanan as
you know the so called kissing a realist
and so well generally against it and the
same is true of a kind of isolationist
conservative force in Britain of which
my brother is a pardon me and he yeah at
one point says the war in Afghanistan is
the sort of stupid left-wing war the
only someone like my brother could
possibly support but there's more truth
in that I find than in the rather cheap
allegation made that if you are in favor
for the liberation of Iraq who somehow
become right-wing which I also try and
deal with in the book I have a chapter
about my experiences in Iraq going back
to the 70s on the back of your book or
the typical blurbs that a book would
have and Christopher Buckley for
instance says that you're the greatest
living essayist in the English language
a suite of him
Gore Vidal's if he wished to nominate a
successor he writes an inheritor of Bill
fat I have decided to name Christopher
Hitchens that's on here but it's marked
out yes we'll go brother took that back
the other day we had a very big
falling-out over
and I live where he made the I think
disgraceful suggestion that it was an
inside job in which the administration
are taking part I can't that's more than
a different set of politics it's not a
difference of emphasis I find that
unshakable that's all at all and so he
made a cover all the sour remarks about
me at one point even seemed he would
suggest that I had made that statement
not at any rate it seems to me he was
taking it back so I thought well I would
I went wait from the stage about that
I'll take it back myself but I did it in
a somewhat special way as i quote he is
said to like a feud well i mean i think
he should have won Chris Hitchens yes
the bane of my life my ugly my ugly
younger brother hum I've tried to
obliterate him ever since I was small my
mother hated you're calling me Chris if
your next name is Hitchens Chris
Hitchens means the H is almost bound to
go it's pretty vulgar Christopher's a
nice name Chris isn't I say that even
though Christopher Buckley calls himself
Chris I wish he wouldn't Christoph
actually is what I call him we
compromise on that people at school
would try and call me that and it's
actually it can be very different in
America because people here
fantastically friendly and they like to
get to first-name terms very fast and
then shorten them to even more friendly
almost before you've got to know them so
unless you quickly say at Chad rather
you said Christopher you're gonna sound
like a snob or someone who's you know
repudiating friendly advances so it's
it's a constant battle for me and I
think now I've won it because people
don't call me Chris anymore no one who
knows me it all does and anyway a lot of
my friends call me hitch at last which
is the other reason for the title and
was I discovered when I went to my
father's
navel reunion he took me to a reunion of
his old shipmates years ago before he
died rather touchingly it was I think it
was the last reunion they were gonna
have his old sea dogs and I noticed the
Dale called him here I'd never known
that before and that was what my friends
were the games poor me so that's a
another reason another another fold or
wrinkle in the title what was the
process of writing a memoir like for you
well it was a good bit harder than I had
expected it would be and I tried to work
out why it was giving me such a hard
time and there are two or three reasons
I think one usually what I write I'm
trying to make a case or push an
argument not always but most of the time
or at least I know exactly what I'm
doing I'm trying to describe a foreign
country say as best I can I've done a
fair bit of that with this I'm not
making a case not making an argument
it's not an apologia so this sort of
style of writing gets a little softer
perhaps if you're not careful and then
again I would normally be trying to see
how much I could pack into a given
number of words 5,000 for an article say
or long essay might be more or short
book will be 90,000 how much you can
press into this when you're trying to
remember things if you're like me
there's a very good memory you may will
find you're remembering more than you
thought you would and then you think I
must get this john while it's still in
my cortex so things start to balloon
rather alarmingly are not being cursed
at all you're being very discursive and
that was another difficulty I turned in
almost twice as much as the publisher
originally asked for I've never done
that before and then of course in
Asianet you don't know how it's going to
end
or to be exact Caillou ended I had a
very hard time wrapping it up I didn't
know really when I was done in fact I'm
not done I wake up every day thinking
down I should have put that in or I
should have put that differently but
more often than not something I
remembered that it's too late to put in
now people say it's a good sign
it gives me the blues Perdue
if you're still rising it in your head
it may have some vitality to it hope so
anyway
Christopher Hitchens his memoir hits 22
this weekend on book TVs in depth noted
feminist author and legal Scott